do you think that
most hollywood filmmakers started out as
quote-unquote working-class filmmakers
or do you think that
there was something that was different
in their journey
yeah it's uh it's hard to say i'm i'm
certainly not a hollywood filmmaker so
it's hard to
know exactly but from you know what i've
gathered over the years watching many
interviews going to film festivals
meeting some filmmakers that i love
um i've understood that i feel like
there's two paths to do it there's
the
the hardest path which is almost like
playing the lottery which is essentially
making sure you know you are in the
right place at the right time with the
right people and you have a bunch of
connections and you have a bunch of you
know people around you who know how to
make this happen
and you're also privileged enough to you
know have all those connections fall
into place so you know that's tough
because you know 99 of people
can't quite get there
um but i think a lot of times
the other route which is kind of i guess
the way i'd like to go which is maybe
the the road less traveled which i feel
like you know is just making many
smaller films over a period of time and
and trying to make an impact with that
you know and seeing what can happen and
seeing what is available to you with you
know the resources you have around you
um so i would certainly kind of look at
it that way
but it is certainly interesting because
i think a lot of times people think the
hollywood way is the only way and i
think with with time uh people are
seeing that it's not
well since you've done music videos um
you've probably seen bands or
artists whatever in the music industry
that probably maybe they didn't set out
to be big names but then somehow
their career took them that way i wonder
if that's just the way it happens it's
just people that just really have a
desire to tell something whether it's
through music or film and then ends up
taking them there
yeah um i got to work with a rapper out
of baton rouge named caleb brown who
recently got signed to rostrum records a
couple years back and that was you know
mac miller and wiz khalifa's label um
and you know i kind of got a little peek
behind the curtain of how a big
label runs and it was really interesting
because you know they in their instance
were really kind and they let him do a
lot of his own stuff and you know they
got to
really
trust their artist which i think is rare
um the little bit of understanding i
could gather and that's certainly
different because it's the music
industry um was that a lot of you know
labels don't run that way and so it was
it was interesting to kind of get a
glimpse of that
and then kind of apply it to what i do
which is the film industry
which also does not always run that way
because i think a lot of times if you do
get into the big league so to speak
you sometimes have to compromise some of
your morals or your values or the types
of films you want to make you may have
to you know make that rent check so you
just do something that kind of you know
takes you off the path that you're
hoping to go and sometimes you end up
down that path for a while and you kind
of forget the original path and so you
know i always try to you know as best as
possible stay connected to the the
source message of you know what
resonates with me as an artist
and it seems like so many artists
whatever
the genre uh start out as more the
introverted
kid in their bedroom doodling or you
know creating music or doing a little
film set and they're not really looking
to be part of that
big group they just love doing that and
then
if they're really good it somehow takes
them out into the big group and then
they're like wait a minute i don't know
if i want to be here i like doing it on
my own that's where i feel safe you know
yeah
yeah it's certainly really interesting
because i i kind of feel
that on a personal level for myself like
um i love going to big crews and uh when
i was doing music videos like we we did
a giant crew for one and it was weird
because it was like i don't touch that
camera like that that's his job is like
it would be weird if i went over and
touched that camera and like for me
coming from north carolina like
sometimes we would pass the camera
around to like see different people's
ideas and like that's just not the way
it works on a professional set and
that's okay and that's by design and
certainly like my films now i don't do
that but it's just interesting kind of
like you know life happens fast but
sometimes you blink and you find
yourself on those bigger sets and it's
certainly a very cool experience but
then sometimes
you know people say oh once i'm there
i'm never going back uh one of the
things i did
while i was making that music video was
i was making that couple hundred dollar
tv show in louisiana um home remedy and
two days after i did that big shoot
i drove a couple hours down across
louisiana for a shoot on the tv show
and it was just me and two people with a
canon 60. and so it was like you know i
just wanted to make that story and that
wasn't the story that was going to pay
my bills you know the music video was
but
it was something to me that i didn't
feel like you know just because i got
here didn't mean i couldn't go back to
my roots when i wanted to so
[Music]
we heard you almost didn't go to film
school evan is that true
i thought about a couple different
options um
i ended up going to film school because
i loved the professors who i met i went
to a very small
film school that's within a larger art
department at east carolina university
in north carolina and i loved the the
faculty who were there because they they
truly were
very realistic with me about the odds of
filmmaking um which you would think
would scare people off
but to me actually i appreciated the
the earnestness and the honesty and the
sincerity that they said there they
basically said you know we'll teach you
how to make a film
but it's not going to guarantee that
you're going to go to be spielberg and i
had just gone through a bunch of college
tours at the time with people saying hey
do you want to be the next spielberg do
you want to be the next this and
and it felt gimmicky you know and you
could kind of feel a little bit of the
pull um
and i mean of course someone's going to
be the next whatever right that's just
how the world works but the odds are
that it's probably not going to be you
so instead of billing it as do you want
to be the next insert famous person here
it was built to me as do you want to
know how to do this to almost like
learning a craft like welding or
something like that and to me that was
more interesting um
so they they pitched that and they also
pitched like more practical ways to use
filmmaking you know shooting corporate
videos music videos weddings things like
that like i think a lot of times film
schools try to like shove that part
under the rug a little bit and they say
well that's not glamorous we're only
going to teach you the
the cool stuff you know but but they
kind of opened the whole toolbox and i
certainly appreciated that um and i
think i've taken a little bit of that
with me along the way
it seems like so much of anything that's
um i mean did you watch the last dance
yeah
so if you if you look at some of it it's
incredibly glamorous and you see
but then
the the viewer was allowed to go behind
the scenes to some parts that were very
very painful and then some parts that
weren't that glamorous but we don't
really think about that so i think
that it seems like for a lot of
professions like these the creme de la
creme we don't really see that a lot of
it isn't glamorous and a lot of it's
tedious and
so
i i think it's great that your professor
or professors were a little more
realistic with you and yeah
didn't try to make it seem you know
because i think then people get
blindsided and then
yeah they have dashed expectations they
do yeah and i think that's why there's a
lot of burnout in the film industry and
that's why people you know turn to
things and there's a lot of mental
health issues people don't talk about
and there's just a lot of things that i
think
don't need to be there if we don't set
the expectation
at steven spielberg you know if we maybe
set the expectation at you're learning a
you know a craft you're learning how to
do this so you can tell the stories you
want to tell
certainly doesn't mean anyone's going to
watch but i think it's a lot of times
being realistic with it and also saying
you can get these stories out of your
head and put them out you know and
hopefully with time people will see that
and people will take notice um and and i
appreciate the like you said the
earnestness of that
you